y así está la céntrica plaza bolívar de
bogotá en este 21 de septiembre donde
colombia tanto en bogotá como en otras
ciudades del país han vivido una
caravana social por la vida y la paz uno
de los principales motivos ha sido la
violencia policial después de que hace
dos semanas no hay el 10 de septiembre
muriesen 13 personas por fuego real de
la policía que protestaban por la
brutalidad policial del día anterior de
la muerte de javier ordóñez a manos de
varios policías dos de los cuales han
sido ingresados en prisión vamos a
escuchar a este manifestante a ver qué
nos cuenta porque se está celebrando
esta caravana social el 21 de septiembre
y la verdad yo preste servicio militar
aquí en colombia yo soy soldado fusilero
y mi hermano pues lo que uno le enseña
no no toda la vida que es defender a la
patria al pueblo nuestros policías como
han hechos atropellos
escuchas no les tiembla la mano ni les
templo la mano la semana pasada en
utilizar armas de fuego contra civiles
contra jóvenes problemas de la violencia
policial los sindicatos han marchado
convocados por el comité nacional del
paro desde primera hora de la mañana
para protestar contra los efectos que ha
causado el coronavirus en generando una
crisis social sanitaria y económica que
ha sacado a relucir según los sindicatos
los problemas que vive colombia vamos a
escuchar al presidente de la
confederación general del trabajo la la
pandemia colocó al descubierto todas las
debilidades de un sistema capitalista
que fracasó estruendosamente en colombia
y nosotros ya veníamos con la tasa de
desempleo la segunda más alta de américa
latina- uno de los países más desiguales
del planeta
antes de la pandemia la pandemia que lo
que se coloca en la superficie toda esa
problemática está por ver cómo continúa
este 21 de septiembre la situación
social cuando los movimientos sociales
esperan que se recupere esa ola de
indignación del pasado 2019 cuando el 21
de noviembre un paro nacional convocó a
miles de personas que terminaron con
promesas políticas por parte del
gobierno de reformas que aseguran los
manifestantes de este 21 de septiembre
que todavía no se han cumplido